Cain killed Abel,
Abel Caine's children killed seven
canes,
grandchildren kill 70 fold,
and then tubilcain pops up on the
horizon and he's the person who makes
artifices of war and so the story in its
fragmentary manner ties the individual's
psychopathology that's resentful and
revenge seeking to the proclivity for
broad scale warfare,
and this really hit me because I was
interested particularly in what was
happening in the Nazi camps with the
guards because the guards were
gratuitously cruel and I was very
curious about that.
And so here's an interesting story.
This was in a book called a ordinary
Germans,
Hitler's willing executioners,
and it was a book that was written about
30 years ago.
The challenge,
the idea that the Nazi phenomenon was
taught down order following,
which I don't believe,
by the way I think that that's a very a
week we kype orthosis fascistic
societies are fascistic at every single
level of organization spiritually within
the family,
within the local community.
It's like a holograph.
It's the same.
Absolutely everywhere.
It's not top down.
I mean,
there are leaders who get produced and
maybe they catalyze it,
but to blame it on the leaders is to
forget about the process by which the
leaders come to be.
So No,
you don't get a pass that way.
So here's one of the things that
happened as the Nazis started to lose
the war.
So here's what you should have done.
If you are a Nazi and he wanted to win
the war,
you should have enslaved the Jews and
the Gypsies and had them work,
right?
You should have had them work for the
benefit of the victory.
And then if you want to liquidate them
afterwards,
that's the logical thing to do.
If you want to win and we assume that
Hitler wanted to win,
but that's not a very intelligent
assumption.
Why would you assume that he wasn't
exactly a good guy?
So why should we assume that he was
aiming at the good that he was
promoting,
even in his own terms,
right?
The glorious everlasting for Third
Reich,
right?
That a rule for a thousand years and
being a bastion of civilization and
music because that's the sort of thing
he purported to be interested in.
Well,
so what do you do with the Jews and the
Gypsies?
Well,
round them up,
fine in slave and find you.
Don't kill them.
You certainly don't devote a substantial
proportion of your war resources well,
you're losing to accelerate the rate at
which the extermination is taking place
because that's a bit counterproductive
unless what you're aiming at is the
maximum possible mayhem in the shortest
period of time.
Well,
so what happened as the Germans started
to lose the war,
did Hitler lose faith in his own
ability?
No.
He believed that the Germans had to be
traded with weakness and so he's
perfectly willing to accelerate the rate
at which Germany was losing the war and
so when Hitler and his minions had the
choice,
here's the choice.
You can suspend your unnecessary
demolition of people when the damn war
and then pick it up afterwards or while
you're losing.
You can just accelerate.
The may have,
even though it's was like,
did they pick?
Well,
they picked to accelerate the mayhem and
so to me there's an old psychoanalytic
idea.
I think this was derived by young.
If you can't figure out what someone is
doing or why,
look at the outcome and infer the
motivation.
If it produces may him,
perhaps it was aiming at me hip.
Now you know,
you have to use that dictum carefully.
If someone's irritating,
you know,
maybe it's because you're irritable,
had you should sort yourself out,
but maybe it's because they're actually
aiming at irritating you and that's the
actual motivation.
So perhaps not,
but it's another tool in your analytical
armament.
So and so you see,
well this is the thing about warfare
that's so interesting about,
about,
because you can,
you can attribute it to territory,
let you can attribute it to a war for
resources.
That's what the,
I would say wretchedly
simple minded economists presume people
fight over scarce resources.
It's like,
hey,
we're a little bit more sophisticated
than that.
And first of all,
what resources are you talking about?
The bloody anyway,
it had nothing.
They live perfectly well.
What did they have?
Snow and seal.
Blubber.
You know,
people can live and unbelievably
deprived conditions,
and so the idea that there are natural
resources that we fight over because
there's a shortage of them is a pretty
oversimplified view of human beings.
It's like,
well,
why do people fight?
Well,
maybe they fight sometimes for good
reasons,
but very,
very frequently they fight for bad
reasons and those bad reasons are our
personal as well as sociocultural and
economic.
You know,
if you were announced a prison guard,
for example,
whatever pathologies you were carrying
around in your destructive little soul,
whatever element of Cain was deeply
embedded in you had the opportunity to
be manifest foley at every moment of
your waking existence.
Right?
You had these people who were completely
beholden to you with no rights
whatsoever,
to whom you could do whatever you're
evil little heart determined think,
well,
maybe that was a motivation for putting
them there to begin with and all the
cover story about,
well,
we're trying to build the Third Reich
and we're trying to stabilize the state
and we're trying to do all these good
things.
Maybe that's just a cover story for the
real motivation,
which is nothing but,
but what the construction of death camps
that killed 6 million people,
how about that and the obliteration of
120 million people on the planet and the
and the and the and the leaving of
European runes.
Maybe that was the motivation or are we
going to attribute to Hitler the highest
possible motives?
Say No,
it's an archetype of manifestation of
cane.
Now he's going to put up a front that
says,
well,
I'm your savior.
It's like,
well,
destructive people think that cane is
their savior.